I committed myself in,
in my book Keynes,
the return of the master to the view
that the blame lies chiefly with the
economists.
I because of my,
uh,
conviction that ideas matter and that
other people,
they're not just puppets of ideas,
but what's what goes on in their heads.
What they think about the world is
really provided by,
uh,
the thinkers and in this case the
economist.
And that shapes their actions to an
extraordinary degree.
It's not enough to say,
look,
bankers were,
were,
were immensely greedy and that they
committed lots of frauds.
I mean that's not that they were set
free.
That sort of particular proclivity in
human nature was set free to do its best
and its worst.
Well who set it free?
Well obviously regulators and
governments,
but politicians and regulators or
consumers of ideas,
they never have any ideas of their own.
Um,
if it take too much,
too much,
like hard work to develop ideas or you
get them on,
you get them off menus and you pick the
ones that suit you and say they were
the,
so there was this chain and I think that
was the important thing.
If you like financial intermediation,
financial services was set free to go
beyond their rightful place.
A place by which they had been
restrained in the past.
And I think in the periods when they
were restrained,
economies were much more stable and
they,
they became later on.
So that's my basic answer.
It's the ideas that are important.
By the time you're in a hole,
I mean the crisis remember came on very,
very suddenly.
You could say it had been germinating
for the previous year.
Of course people were alert to things
even in 2007 but you know,
then hit with a thunder clap.
And within a month it was as though the
whole of the western banking system was
about to be wiped out.
And that's when they came in very,
very fast.
Governments and,
and,
and central banks.
And then after that they have to say,
okay,
now we're in this whole,
how do we sort of nudge,
nudge economies out of it?
Because economies with,
by this time,
our life support system,
the banks are on life support system and
the real economy was starting to be on a
life support system.
So Keynes I think would have,
would have actually approved of most of
that.
I think some things he would have done
in different way.
But do they go back to the old,
old question?
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
it's almost no use asking what would he
have done in detail because things have
changed.
But it's the spirit,
uh,
his,
his analysis and the spirit in which he
would have tackled these problems that
are important.
And I think he would have been on the
side of expanding,
uh,
always.
When you're sliding down a rather than a
buttoning up your coats and,
and,
and saying,
we must,
we must tighten,
tighten our belts.
Cause I think he would have thought that
would have brought to us,
bring us even lower than,
than,
than we,
than we've gone
[inaudible].